we got IQ of a million really hmm
as funny as an atheist people say would
you believe in aliens like that's an
equatable question I will know it
because we're living proof that there is
life on the planet so they're definitely
they're definitely possible and you know
with the amount of Suns and you know the
chances are there's something would it
be a little green man but then tonight
flying a ship probably not probably like
a giant slug we get to them first no
what kept ago was just a [ __ ] slug
the could dear father's like it could be
so I don't know I might be but uh all
right lads huh
all right lads yeah intelligent [ __ ]
bright as a bun
we're just a lot a big [ __ ] you fat lug
oh I don't think got the [ __ ] hands
it's what we got IQ of a million really
mm-hmm
oh you [ __ ] poor just [ __ ] brains
just brains go around an outgoing
[ __ ] working everything out
[ __ ] watch a stiff [ __ ] beating
people that chess in 30 seconds I've
done more [ __ ] for a fast load never
know dear what's the question
[Applause]